Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you’re watching
the Today I Found Out youtube channel, in
the video today, we’re looking at the husband
and wife team that gave us the first commercially
viable automobile, the Model 3, and the impromptu
road trip that saved it from obscurity.
We may not have flying cars quite yet, but
the ground-bound automobile is the world’s
second most popular mode of transportation
(behind the bicycle).
Many think Henry Ford invented the car, but
that isn’t correct.
While Ford certainly made the automobile affordable
for the middle-class, it was actually a German
engineer with a familiar name that invented
the first commercially available petrol-powered
motor vehicle.
In 1885, Karl Benz created what he later would
call the “Motorwagen.”
However, this wasn’t an invention of a single
man.
He had help from someone else - his wife,
Bertha Benz.
Credited as the first person ever to take
a so-called automobile "road trip," she also
discovered various issues with her husband's
invention during the drive, coming up with
some very innovative ideas in the process,
such as inventing the brake pad mid-trip.
As with many inventions, Benz’s Motorwagen
wasn’t a design that just came out of nowhere.
It was a product of innovation-evolution,
simply the next iteration of a long line of
previous inventions.
Perhaps the first vision of a horseless, mechanical
cart came from Leonardo da Vinci in 1479.
Titling it “Design for Spring-Driven Car
or Horseless Wagon,” there’s no proof
he actually built it but his sketch looks
like a spring-loaded tricycle.
A few hundred years later, steam engines were
also used in attempts to replace the horse-drawn
carriage.
In 1769, Frenchman Nicolas-Joseph Cugnot constructed
what is regarded as the first working self-propelled
vehicle intended for human travel.
Essentially a large steam-powered tricycle,
its top speed was slower than a brisk walk
(about two miles an hour).
This doesn’t include the four or five times
it needed to stop per hour for water refill
and to allow the steam pressure to build back
up.
Needless to say, this was not practical.
Six decades later, Scotsman Robert Anderson
put a non-rechargeable battery on a carriage
and it moved...albeit not very fast and for
very long.
Fellow countryman Robert Davidson expanded
on this innovation, creating a battery in
1841 that could propel a carriage to go 1.5
miles in less than thirty minutes.
Then, unfortunately, it needed a new battery.
While several advancements were made on the
electric car front (in fact in 1899 90% of
New York City’s Taxi Cabs Were Electric
Vehicles and the First Gas / Electric Hybrid
was Built in 1900), for various reasons it
wouldn't be until the 21st century that we
have finally gone full circle and started
coming up with commercially viable electric
cars, with cars such as the Nissan Leaf, Chevy
Bolt, and Tesla Model S, Model X, and Model
3, the last of which shares the name of the
car we'll be discussing today.
This brings us to the internal combustion
engine, which, much like the automobile, has
its own evolutionary history.
The first combustion engines didn't take advantage
of any sort of internal compression and weren't
particularly powerful or practical.
In 1806, Swiss engineer François Isaac de
Rivaz was the first to construct an internal
combustion engine that used hydrogen and oxygen.
More explosive, it did at least provide the
germ of an idea for several other inventors
and their inventions, including Jean Joseph
Etienne Lenoir’s “Hippomobile.”
Considered the first successful horseless
carriage powered by an internal combustible
engine, it was patented by Lenoir in 1860
and looks more ship-like than car.
American George Brayton was the first to develop
a kerosene-fueled engine in 1873, but that
also didn’t provide enough power for a commercially
viable automobile.
12 years later, Benz used these previous innovations
to influence his own design for what is generally
considered the first "modern" automobile.
Born in the southwest German city of Karlsruhe
in 1844, Karl Benz’s father died in a railway
accident when he was only two years old.
Despite being poor, his mother made sure his
education got top priority, rather than sending
him off to work in some factory or the like
as so many others in such situations had to
do.
Always a scientific-minded student who loved
riding his bicycle (a relatively new invention
at the time), he entered the University of
Karlsruhe at 15 years old.
He graduated in July 1864 and began seven
long years working various jobs at mechanical
engineering companies.
Eventually he saved enough money to open his
own iron construction business with a business
partner, August Ritter.
Almost immediately the company started going
down the toilet, largely thanks to issues
with Ritter.
Benz was on the verge of bankruptcy when he
met Bertha Ringer.
Ringer was the daughter of a wealthy family
from the nearby German town of Pforzheim and
didn’t have a lot in common with Benz from
a socioeconomic standpoint.
But she believed in him.
As Benz himself would later note in his memoirs,
"Only one person remained with me in the small
ship of life when it seemed destined to sink.
That was my wife.
Bravely and resolutely she set the new sails
of hope."
As an unmarried woman of privilege, she was
awarded a rather large dowry that was to be
relinquished to her husband upon marriage
in order that she might continue to lead her
accustomed affluent lifestyle - but until
that time, it was hers to manage how she saw
fit.
Now, it is unclear how Karl and Bertha met,
but it’s very evident that they had a special
relationship.
In 1870 - two years before they married - Bertha
chose to invest a significant amount of her
dowry in Benz's business to help ensure his
company’s financial survival.
While this kept the business afloat, unfortunately,
due to various issues with other shareholders
and Benz' role in the company ultimately becoming
marginalized, he was forced to leave this
business.
But thanks to the rest of Bertha's dowry,
he was able to start a new company, Benz & Cie.
Now without interference from shareholders
or business partners, Benz began working on
whatever pleased him.
And what pleased him was engineering several
components that today are associated with
modern-day vehicles.
He then patented these devices and sold the
patents to subsidize his other inventing.
These included patents for a throttle system,
battery-powered ignition systems, spark plugs,
gear shifters, carburetors, the water radiator,
and the clutch.
A commonly told legend has it that, looking
for a distraction one day, Benz visited a
nearby bicycle shop to indulge his lifelong
passion for the two wheeler.
He, instead, became inspired that day and
went back into his shop and invented a new
type of human transportation device.
In truth, Benz, and many others, had long
been seeking to create such a device and he
had devoted much of his professional life
to inventing and improving upon the necessary
mechanisms to make such a vehicle possible.
It took several years of tinkering, but in
January of 1886, he was able to patent his
“Motorwagen” - a three-wheeled vehicle
with a one-cylinder, four-stroke gasoline
engine.
While others, such as Gottlieb Daimler, were
independently working on essentially the same
thing with similar success, it was the Motorwagen
that is credited as the world’s first practical,
commercially available, internal combustion
engine powered automobile.
After completing the Motorwagen, Benz demonstrated
it to the public, hoping to garner some sales,
or at least get someone interested in acquiring
rights to the patent.
The demonstrations didn’t go so well, with
one resulting in the driver crashing into
a wall and scaring onlookers.
Benz, who suffered from bouts of depression
and extreme self-doubt, went back to his workshop
and continued to try to perfect his device.
Knowing her husband's lack of confidence and
perfectionism all-to-well, and frightened
that his invention would end in the dustpan
of history, Bertha decided to take matters
into her own hands.
It was in August of 1888 when Bertha decided
to execute her plan.
Awaking early in the morning, she and two
of her teen sons, Eugen and Richard, pushed
the so-called Motorwagen Model 3 out of her
husband’s workshop and far enough away where
it could be started without waking him up.
The purpose of the little joyride she had
planned was to visit her mother in Pforzheim,
65 miles away.
In the process, she hoped to drum up a considerable
amount of publicity, doing something that
had never been tried before- taking an automobile
on a road trip.
Bertha did not inform Karl of this adventure
beforehand, but rather left him a note that
he discovered when he woke up.
Unfortunately for history buffs the world-over,
exactly what this note said has been lost
to history.
The road to Pforzheim was certainly less-traveled,
rocky and unpaved in many places.
(Aside: the poem The Road Not Taken probably
doesn't say what you think it says, see our
video Robert Frost’s Commonly Misinterpreted
“The Road Not Taken” and the Role it Played
in the Death of His Best Friend) Despite the
driving conditions, Bertha was determined,
driving and repairing the car on the way.
She and her sons had to push the car up many
of the hills (which later led her to suggest
that the Model 3 needed a lower gear as the
2.5 horsepower engine simply wasn't sufficient
for hill climbing).
She also had to stop for fuel at pharmacies
that sold ligroin and was forced to make an
emergency repair to the car’s ignition using,
of all things, her garter to insulate a shorted
wire.
When the fuel line became clogged, she identified
the problem and cleared it with her hairpin.
When the drive chain broke, she found a blacksmith
and instructed him on how to make the needed
repair.
When the wooden brakes began to crack in the
face of sustained downhill usage, she came
up with the idea of putting leather on the
wooden shoes- the world's first automobile
brake pads- finding a shoemaker to provide
and attach leather soles for this function.
(Along with adding the extra gear and certain
minor tweaks based on his wife's feedback,
this was another improvement Benz would immediately
add to the Model 3's design upon Bertha's
return.)
At dusk, Bertha Benz arrived at her mother’s
home, having made the 65 mile trip, repair
time included, in less than 12 hours.
All along the way, excited villagers and bystanders
witnessed the marvel that was the Motorwagen
- sure, it wasn’t perfect, but it moved
relatively fast and it was safe.
She sent a telegram to her husband to tell
him of the successful journey, but he already
knew due to the significant publicity that
echoed across the region thanks to her audacious
road trip.
Bertha had saved him before with her money-
this time she did it with her gumption and
faith that his invention could do what no
others like it had ever done.
After several days at her mother’s, Bertha
and the boys returned home in the Motorwagen,
this time intentionally going in a different
direction, impressing even more people with
the Model 3.
All in all, it was the world’s first automobile
road trip- 120 miles in less than 24 hours
of driving, including repair and refueling
time.
Prior to this, the only other known internal
combustion automobiles hadn't managed more
than a mile, and often had to be returned
by rail, pushed, or pulled by horses after
having broken down.
Directly after this well publicized road trip,
orders started coming in for Benz' Motorwagen.
By the end of the century, Benz' company was
producing hundreds of cars per year and was
the largest automobile manufacturer in the
world.
While Karl Benz was a phenomenal engineer
and visionary, history almost certainly only
remembers him, instead of so many others that
were inventing virtually the same thing around
this same time, because of the constant financial
support and later keen promotional sense of
his wife, Bertha Ringer Benz.
Once again, as the man himself said, "Only
one person remained with me in the small ship
of life when it seemed destined to sink.
That was my wife.
Bravely and resolutely she set the new sails
of hope."